[Music]
what was your plan back
there it's like a 14-hour drive to get
to Santa Fe didn't think that far ahead
to be honest dad you're pretty out of
shape
[Music]
though are you
hungry a sweet tooth you got from
me
H is that all I got from
you
somebody order a
stripper can I get you anything I'll
take a
[Music]
beer oh hey oh okay let's go no we're
just having a conversation excuse me 12
hours ago 12 hours ago you
OD trust me this path you're on is not
worth it what are you care you're an
addict guess who I learned that
[Music]
from I've been there and um my life
started to slip away I just couldn't
stop I didn't really know what it meant
to be a
father but I would like to get to know
you why would I ever trust you you've
never been there for me Dad
I'm just trying to find my
[Music]
[Applause]
daughter live your
life there's something greater something
better come
on come on I don't care what they say
I'm in love with you they trying to pull
me
but they don't know the
[Music]
truth